I always say I wonder if you're caught
up I'm missing something there's
something very small that's perceived
from this that probably you wouldn't
lose a mark for but as a map
mathematician you should not get away
without writing what you're saying okay
so at a certain point i multiplied
through I have multiplied through and um
well okay so first art is like just to
write this thing which really I should
have if you're talking about the value K
because anyone I really should have said
it much earlier okay but this way the
part that's problematic is this
inequality I've said it's not going to
change direction at this point okay the
reason for that is because k plus 1 k
plus 1 the smallest value k can take is
zero so the small value k plus 1 can
take is one and two and three and four
and five so therefore i should be able
to say here now k plus 1 is positive and
that's why this inequality stays the way
it is whereas down here it fits around
okay now mine another point which you
should cut down see this number here
it's three and a half okay so that means
for all that is less than that the
coefficient keeps getting bigger if this
is a whole number this is an integer
some kind then you don't get one
greatest coefficient you get to the two
equal ones right I'll let you ponder why
that is okay just have a think about it
but for now I just want you to know that
it's true now i'm going to use this to
actually solve a question okay so
remember in a care has to be an integer
right that means that the coefficients
are increasing for which values of k k
equals
the 0 1 1 323 yeah these all satisfied
yes okay but um it's you don't drive
this really but um it's decreasing for K
equals that's just the last one it's
just the last one oh I can have 525 okay
so therefore what I'm going to do is off
of this i'm going to write a big long
inequality that helps me identify which
term i need in other words this one i'm
going to say look the coefficients keep
on increasing from c0 is going to be
less than C 1 which is going to Nessus
c2 which is going to be less than C 3
yeah I kept pause for a second is the
coefficient for the next one got a
bigger or smaller like as in join me
write it this way or this way lesser
than or greater than I get so so here's
his option one that's the one and here
is option two yes watch it again oh yeah
the second one is critical yeah is it
this one oh it was the greatest 11 okay
so this is and you see why i'm building
on this because this is where students
have done all this wonderful work and
then the last hurdle move wait which one
is it okay so thing about this right
coefficients are increasing for these
particular values now what this does is
it compares what you are now to the next
one right what you are now to the next
one what you are now to the next one and
when I'm there to get to the next one
I've gotta multiply by some number
bigger than one right which means that
the next one along c4 is still going to
be bigger
okay think about it and you can just
write them out remember go back to the
old table that you drew right um 10
minutes ago ok have a look at what point
the inequality stops working right so I
think for a memory or c2 c2 it's okay
that's the last one it's like what was
it too i think it was was the actual
value right so that means I've got a
modified it to to get by two to get to
the next coefficient and then after that
it stops okay so you wanted that next
one that guy there's your k plus 1 does
that make sense another way you can
think about this is if k is less than
three and a half k equals three is the
biggest value that satisfy the satisfied
news but k plus 1 k plus what we wrote
we all wrote this down right k plus 1 is
the greatest code vision okay so
therefore number 4 has to be okay so
just to tell you something to burn
therefore what is c4 like that's the
actual thing I want to work out where do
i go to find out what the greatest
coefficient is I belonged on the board
where am I gonna go I think I'm going to
go here right when I that's the best way
to go this is TK so I just want this
part without the X because i'm not
worried about that fit so I'm gonna say
C 4 is equal to all right 5c four times
one power of 1 times 3 to the power of
all let's find to see four that's five
right that's five times 3 to the 4 which
is anyone so this is 405 okay now you
might recall I said I chose this number
to the power 5 because you can actually
write it out you can actually do it it's
just within the Rams are being able to
do so here's the expansion this is the
actual if you had done it by health hand
right so in confirmation of what we just
found yes it is coefficient for which is
the fifth turn in there but that's just
if you're counting okay